now we can talk to the man who's been
crunching through all the numbers our
election analysts Professor Michael
Thrasher is here with us now of course
there's lots of caveats right because
people vote differently in locals and
Generals but what do you make of the big
reveal
I think it's something that we've known
for quite some time but it is nice to
see actual numbers here we speculated
quite early on that labor had done well
but not well enough because it has an
enormous mountain to climb to win an
overall majority of the next general
action you can say this is a big swing
and the conservative vote is down
substantially from the 45 that it got in
2019 to just 29 now so that's very sharp
full a modest rise for labor but
nevertheless a big swing conservative
labor but it's not enough to win an
overall majority so that we're in that
intriguing position where the
conservatives easily lose their overall
majority the conservatives lose so many
seats that there's no coming back in
terms of you know the um discussion
about who would form a minority
government it would be labor but again
28 seats of an overall majority so we're
in that interesting territory of what
happens after this do they go into a
minority government do they try and form
a coalition it was interesting the first
thing that you said Sam when you looked
at that was like oh hang on that means
that labor along with the lived ends
that would be enough they wouldn't need
the SNP that's right this is an enormous
moment and this underscores how this set
of Elections has been incredibly
important because it's crystallized a
big change in the way that the British
public are looking at politics
you can say on the basis of the result
that it now looks incredibly unlikely if
it results at anything like this that
Rishi sudak conservatives will be in
Downing Street after the next general
election but labor doesn't as Michael
says quite meet the threshold for an
overall majority in other words there'll
be a hung Parliament under these results
under that projection that you can see
on the screen behind you but we are 28
seats short of a majority which will
give you a majority plus two but
it is a good deal easier to work
alongside the liberal Democrats who
after all are a unionist party as well
that it would be the SMP and if the
liberal Democrats are on 39 that gives
you more than enough to take you over
the 3236 threshold it would have been a
lot more difficult for kirstama had that
result be less good for labor and
potentially had to rely on the SNP as
well to get him over the line now I am
sure that the conservative party will
make absolute hay of the fact that the
conservative that the labor party don't
go over that 326 line there will be
stories briefed every day between now
and the election about the chaos of a
potential minority or who Coalition and
these kids divers struggling up and all
the rest of it worth saying of course
that you know conservatives are a
coalition with their own party with
various faction various wings that have
kind of pushed British politics in all
sorts of ways in the last uh last few
years but the labor party are going to
have to answer questions about how how
they would deal with the hung Parliament
but I think there will be a sigh of
relief that if that is the question they
could probably do it with the help of
the liberal Democrats rather than
needing nationalists in order to get
there just as we've been talking seeing
the conservatives they're losing at
Canterbury to no overall control again
just really echoing the story that we've
been seeing of conservatives dropping
seats losing control of councils
um Michael
um it does feel to me like I know
exactly what labor would say if they
looked at that they'd be saying look
this is not fair we've been winning in
loads the places that we've been
targeting that we need to in order to
get to that majority others wouldn't
have 75 seats in the House of Commons
plus you're not even taking to account
what's happening in Scotland with the
difficulties of the SNP they are
convinced they've got a path to a
majority I think some I think some of
those remarks are are valid and we
really don't know what is going to
happen with the SMP labor Battleground
at the next general election because we
don't I don't know the impact on the SMP
of recent events
but labor cannot deny that for this set
of local elections there haven't been
the only party that's advancing against
the conservatives the liberal Democrat
gains both in terms of seats and
councils is rather impressive their
advance in terms of vote share is
impressive and they've tripled the
number of MPS that they have so and and
again
um Sam says the Intriguing Prospect is
that they can do a deal with the liberal
Democrats but you know it's not
necessarily
um that their ideal position so I agree
that they can make the argument about
the SNP but you know it's it's a
question they cannot deny that the lib
dams have had a good election just as
good as they've had
just a little bit of Intel from the
labor party and I want to know what you
make of it
um we've been curious about just how
many seats the labor party think they
need to rely on from the SMP turning
labor in order to give them an overall
majority and I've got a figure
the labor party understand think that
they could rely on conservatively just
12 to 15. so not a huge number of seats
but that means they need to do better in
England how credible is it for the labor
party to say we can get an overall
majority if they're only relying on 12
to 15 seats swapping from SMP to labor
no labor government has formed with
fewer than 40 seats coming from Scotland
even in their Landslide they they had
large numbers of seats from Scotland it
was the kind it was the banker wasn't it
they would start with a whole load of
seats in Scotland and then suddenly
they've lost them and they've been in
opposition for a long time I don't find
that sort of thesis really credible in
terms of such a small number come from
Scotland because what we haven't seen
what we've seen across part of the south
of England is liberal Democrats
advancing labor advancing in some areas
but not across the board in the same way
that Blair did in 95 and then on into
the general election and for every seat
that it fails to make inroads in terms
of Southern England it's got to find
them somewhere and it's got to be in
Scotland and fascinating to talk to you
both thank you very much for sharing the
protections with us and I think it
really does underline the mountain that
labor do have to climb in a swing that
they need to find in order to get a
majority at the next election that is
difficult